president-elect joe biden maintains the
president is not fit for office
after calling on the senate to quickly
confirm his cabinet on friday
mr biden appeared to have found common
ground with mr trump
he no longer believes having president
trump at his inauguration
will send a powerful message to the
world about a peaceful transfer of power
and it appears mr trump agrees nicole
killian is with the president-elect in
wilmington delaware this morning nicole
does
mr biden believe the president should be
removed from office
dana president-elect biden said the
quickest way for
president trump to go is when he and
vice president-elect harris
are sworn in january 20th
one of the few things he and i have ever
agreed on
it's a good thing i'm not showing up
president-elect joe biden
unfazed after president trump announced
he will not attend the inauguration
what about the vice president welcome
i think it's important that um the
as much as we can stick to what have
been
the historical precedence of how in a
circumstance in which
an administration changes should be
maintained
the president-elect steered clear of
whether the president should be
impeached
look i i've thought for a long long time
that president trump wasn't fit to hold
the job what the congress decides to do
is for them to decide but mr biden
didn't just lay blame on the president
for wednesday's riots
[Music]
he also pointed the finger at republican
senators who objected to the electoral
results
like texas's ted cruz and missouri's
josh hawley
should senator cruz or senator hawley
resign
i think they should be just flat beaten
the next time they run
i think the american public has a real
good clear look at who they are
they're part of the big lie mr biden
then referenced nazi propagandist joseph
goebbels
you know goebbel's in the great lie you
keep repeating the lie repeating the lie
and accused the senators a parroting
election falsehood spread by president
trump
trump said that before he ran if you say
it enough
i'm going to convince you i'll say it
enough
the press is bad the press is bad the
press is bad the press is bad
if he's the only one saying it that's
one thing but the acolytes that follow
him
like cruz and others they are as
responsible as he is
in a tweet senator cruz responded by
saying president-elect biden's comments
do
nothing to bring us together and promote
healing
senator holly called biden's remarks
utterly shameful and said he should
retract them michelle one interesting
thing to note is while the
president-elect didn't explicitly call
for their resignation
one of his top allies delaware senator
chris coons has
wow nicole thank you